like a guy who arrested me no [__]
he looks like a [__] guy they all
dressed like you
[Laughter]
dressed like they ain't got no money
yeah
this is like sporty athleisure you know
what I mean no I'm not saying no no this
is like a good dress down thing
I hate jokes
bomber jacket gonna pour the milk on me
we gotta go in the bathroom real quick
when uh when I got arrested I offered
you know I tried to bribe the cops and
[__] wait really yeah of course bro how
often does that work well I'm over one
yeah
so so but it's it's not the feds it's
just three local PDS bro it was the
local Vice so I was like this is the
time to do it yeah and I'm like look at
[__] you're looking at a half a
million dollars in cash right now your
boss is not here none of the boys are
here uh I will go get you another 200
you just gotta give me a day and I gotta
get I gotta run I gotta make a run for
it this is my crazy brain I'm like I got
money hidden in all type of places I'm
gonna I'm gonna run for the Border I'm
gonna go to Mexico and then Colombia
this is my thinking so yeah I try to you
know
okay how'd you pitch it
Mario Kart's still fine just that yeah
you literally just that I was like I was
like they come in the room yeah yeah
yeah you hate your jobs your wives are
fat okay with that you're wiser I was
actually really smart yeah that was
probably the best thing you could have
said
um
no it was it was it was just one guy in
there because they they had like three
or I think man there were four Dudes
there and they were walking in and out
they're on their walkie-talkies like if
you heard of this guy John Mitchell
because you know when you your name is
in the system it's bouncing around you
know they're calling Homeland Security
they're they're calling the de have you
heard of this guy nothing nothing
nothing he's got to be connected with a
cartel because they saw the kind of
money that I had in one place and they
were like oh he's clearly this guy's a
big time coke dealer heroin deal they
just had no idea about no [__] idea
plenty of money in one place well it
wasn't all the money in one place but it
was just a big ship yeah exactly it was
the one the money was the one thing that
I just didn't trust anybody to hold for
me not really you know what I mean it's
a hard thing I want to get into the
money thing a little bit yeah after this
okay so so there's one guy so and he was
like the nice guy you know yeah you got
your [__] and you get your nice guy
yeah uh and he was like look you could
just sign a quick you just give a quick
confession and like we will kick you
loose and like we'll let you go out
there and keep dealing right saying this
to you of course this is how it works
dude this is how it works and explain
why Gwen because when you're out there
do you believe it because when you're
out there dealing you can go just like
the cartel a Kingpin in Mexico every now
and then has got to feed the government
uh a Rival Dealer it happens on the
street level too like we're gonna kick
you loose we just caught you with an
ounce of heroin we're gonna kick you
loose and keep dealing but every month
[__] we gotta we need something
we're going to need something oh so you
basically become the Informer you
basically become the informant you
become but you're still dealing so
they're allowing crime to happen always
right
never not even trying to get the bigger
fish bro it's just it's all another
quotas they need three [__] a
month and it's like podcasts all that
matters is numbers
I just saw some [__] online uh the other
day they're the average salary for an
informant is like 80k 80k
yeah I didn't know you get paid need to
be an informed oh yeah yeah so why are
they still dealing because you have to
deal that's how you do that
you can't inform if you're not in the
game you're doing the work for them yeah
that's why everybody I'm giving deals to
everybody
everybody's getting free weeds 80k a
year to snitch that's one of the most
drug dealers yeah I know you know so
yeah it's pretty everybody station
um
and I was like you know like of course
I'm I can't do that you know what I mean
yeah uh and the whole time I'm still
thinking like I'm gonna get back into
this like I'm somehow I'm gonna wiggle
out of this so I don't have any drugs
they don't got money that's all they got
yeah and you know you're not snitching
yeah you're assuming the People Back
Home aren't snitching no no no I assumed
it they were snitching I assumed my
drivers my mules were snitching my
brain's going crazy who's telling I
don't know at this point exactly until
we get the discovery paperwork how they
pop me and they pop you just from the
UPS [__] somebody smelled it exactly
exactly and you know this iPhones have
just come out so uh they were able to
trace like where I had been they just
plug this little machine the cell tower
exactly and I was like oh boy oh boy
they can't they don't they can't tell
exactly where you are they can just tell
exactly
exactly yeah there's Towers everywhere
now so let's try to bribe the officer
what would they get you on you just have
a lot of money uh they had they would
get me on well they got me on money
laundering conspiracy there there was
weed in the house it's just personal
weed but that added up to like a half a
pound
yeah they tied that in and all that uh
so that yeah as they can as much as they
can and then you just knock as many down
when you go to court so so I was just
like
hey I mean and it's not it was not this
smooth okay I'm gonna make myself sound
cool it was not this smooth yeah yeah
because my mouth is right it's like when
you're bombing on stage you have no
saliva in your mouth you're terrified
yeah you know you're like my life is
over this version you know this is
really good I just picture yeah I
picture a black butt [__] yeah
I don't know why it's got to be a black
guy you know because it would be
um
the gayest first in jail wait really of
course of course because the black guys
you guys don't do that sex play [__]
yeah like if you're born before 1990 and
you're black in America like yeah yeah
you're like no games no black kids have
like gay fun yeah
they didn't do that no fart fun yeah
Eddie Murphy said that in the Delirious
yeah my mouth is open okay so all right
so so so yeah give me the pitch so so I
was just like I I had I was like there's
more of this like I was like there's I I
have a safe deposit box I can be back in
an hour before you just gotta let me go
before it closes it was like 3 P.M I'll
go bring you back another 200 000 that's
550 000. nobody's here it's just us four
take it all I just need it I just need a
day to let me know if you paid them off
why why even stop because why even leave
the country because I'm assuming they're
gonna take the money and then still keep
me anyway yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was trying to I was trying to be
reasonable with them I'm like yeah just
let me go I'm not saying you just take
the money and don't charge me yeah just
give me a head start you know what I
mean yeah take 200 000 out charge me
with 350 000 in the [__] thing I'm
not gonna say anything give me 24 hours
to get the hell out of here you could
say that I ran like you could say
whatever you want that's a good deal I'm
trying to like say I'm trying to work
with these guys yeah and these [__]
dorks now if this had been Philly if
this had been the East Coast
they would have pitched it to you yeah
how fast can you get to Columbus
in Florida right
now Northwest dorks you know what
Portland is the worst city in the
[__] country okay yeah I mean so
um so no the guy just looks at me and
you go and he just flipped like he went
from nice guy and he goes you little
[__] piece of [__] and he grabs me
and he and he calls the dudes over and
he's like guess what guess what this
little mother [__] just insinuated and
they were pissed like I thought they
were I thought they were gonna start
[__] me up like really like laying
hands on me they were pissed off about
it yeah so I guess cops think they're
doing good for the community and it's
like it's an insult yeah I guess to a
cop who's straight yeah that he would
even consider taking for sure taking my
money but I'm like come on dude yeah
it's a shot in the dark
it's like when you think a girl's into
you yeah
you got a boyfriend that's fine yeah
that seems unnecessary you know okay oh
I'm just read that entire situation yeah
okay money did they throw extra on it
because you tried yeah it was a bribery
which they couldn't prove though so it's
real it's that's right words recorded
your word versus there and I had to pay
lawyer so we [__] we we got that okay
yeah